hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey i watch the latin on
Sunday night Johnny last night I saw it
Sunday before Game of Thrones aired at
RealD 3d screening Thank You RealD for
inviting me because I had a wonderful
time and the real the experience was
great especially in the musical numbers
I know some people have been a little
bit iffy about whether or not this would
work on 3d take my word for it it
certainly does and lastly I want to
thank everyone who's been downloading
and follow us in the Stardust app over
there with you 30 second reaction
reviews for any film TV show or trailer
sometimes micro sketches we post daily
completely free to download and use
here's my Aladdin Stardust post that can
show you a world where Guy Ritchie
directs a movie with Will Smith as the
genie he is pretty damn good
it has a clunky act one but the rest of
the movie sure is a hell of a lot of fun
a little too on-the-nose of feminism but
some of it got to my heart
enjoy trust me there's many more to talk
about other than what's in that
cringe-worthy bit let's go into this
John what you think I thought this was a
pleasant surprise actually I mean I
didn't love it I thought maybe that this
would be a little better than the
trailer LED on and I kind of got that
experience out of it I thought the leads
were really charming Will Smith actually
is one of the best parts of the movie I
had a wonderful time I think act wanton
is a very clunky it feels very rushed it
feels like I said a rush to get to Act
two and that's when the movie really
started to click for me when you get to
the part where Aladdin does you know get
the lamp on only she's the genie the
part that I was most concerned about
after seeing you know that terrible
visual effects in that teaser Will Smith
singing Prince Holly which just seemed
so cringy when they get to that in that
moment and you get to the number never
had a friend like me that was a dazzling
experience it earned a big round of
applause because during act one I could
feel the audience because I was there
with them unintentionally laughing at
stuff some of us were just out loud
during act one but when you got to that
number I feel like the whole crowd got
one over and we all started applauding
there's a lot of things with the singing
with Will Smith that they do to sort of
mask his lack of power and his vocals
they do a lot of backup vocals a lot of
horrid sermons coming just lend
themselves more to what his voice can do
with a lot of expressive power you know
some of the lower end or some of the
more characterized stuff yeah actually
he does a really good job with it's just
when he asked to do the more Broadway
style singing that it's a little flat
even in those numbers though there's
still plenty to get from it that are so
enjoyable well and the imagination
behind it too because as much as you
know we wondered like all the original
animation was so crazy and how could we
do that live we crap on CGR a lot but
they did some amazing animation and some
really fun dazzling set pieces with
those songs and before going into this I
was worried that this was just gonna be
Will Smith's movie but it wasn't no to
me this is still a Latin in Jasmine's
movie weirdly more Jasmine's movie that
aladdin's movies they don't do anything
different with Aladdin really I really
like the actor who plays Aladdin Meena
Massoud he is Aladdin like you're like
very charming very charismatic I fell in
love myself his scene range is wonderful
Naomi Scott as Jasmine this is where a
lot of the changes really come into play
with every character because of the
modern times we live in are much more of
a character much more of a character
matter of fact in act 1 there's like one
line that happens that's so on the nose
where my girlfriend I looked at each
other and I feel like a lot of people
are gonna pick up on this review and
they're gonna change that ending ru I
think if you've seen it you'll know when
it's all gonna batter it out and if you
haven't seen it even if I didn't say
that you'd be you know already and also
I really loved the chemistry between
aladdin and Jasmine yeah their romance
is so felt in this movie when they got
to the part of a whole new world
I saw her to tear up I didn't see that
coming no we got a boo in here who's a
monkey he's cute he's adorable
he's a boo yeah and you got the carpet
as well who I thought you
had a lot of fun at least
characterization and stuff like that
yeah kind of feel like you won't really
love the carpet unless you've seen the
Aladdin animated movie but most people
who watch this I've seen the 11 animated
movies there's a lot in this movie that
is not in the original animated movie
there's plenty that is but there's also
a lot that isn't they invented brand-new
scenes they rewrote a lot of new scenes
or some new musical numbers in here some
of this stuff in here that I criticize
is it can be a little too on-the-nose
with its feminism I like the ideas I
like the concepts some of it even really
got to my heart same time it's insanely
on the news yeah it's it's like another
one of those things where I really like
the idea and I think it's appropriate
for this character and in a time where
we are seeing Disney retread a lot of
their classics you know and people
complain when they do them too
faithfully I think this is a perfect one
to update it's not on the movies mind to
live very much in that side of the story
in order to earn how much focus it wants
to put on it in a couple of key scenes
it seems like it's really infused in
this read this is a movie word to me at
least I definitely agree the first act
is cha pious but I could definitely feel
the economics of the editing throughout
this movie that's clunky throughout and
yeah that was one of those things that
like Naomi Scott really delivers the
passion and the song because the song is
is meant to bolster those scenes to and
it's to the movies credit that they have
the original composer to make that song
it does stick out a bit like a sore
thumb in the midst of some other stuff
that is a lot more fluid well it's not
just that with the song number it's also
Jafar and Jasmine scenes because every
scene Jafar gets with jasmine is just to
remind her she's a woman and yeah a
silent drinking game out of the amount
of times he tells her to be seen and not
heard
oh yeah it's so often the guy who plays
Jafar I really felt like he gave it his
all he was going for this like human
approach to Jafar as opposed to mustache
twirling villain to me I think he's fine
I think he's good he's honestly the most
forgettable performance out of it but a
lot of that has to do with the writing
and direction of his character they were
trying something different in that I
ultimately feel like didn't really stand
out he was
very close for me and he got a lot of
hate in the trailer for whatever reason
I really liked the actor who played him
I liked Marwan Ken's re a lot as the
character but yeah ultimately he's not
quite there in the writing the most
unexpected character the one who I don't
think anyone really expected anything
out of there's character named alia
played by Nasim pedrad from SNL I
believe she is the scene stealer
she is underlying hilarious scent yeah
this movie I was so surprised like such
a great character to root for her and
one thing that's great about this movie
too is this whole cast whenever they're
interacting they all have good chemistry
I think that was sometimes miss in
movies like this is the individual
performances are good but in samba Liz
not really clicking yeah but I think
whenever Aladdin's would Genie it's
great aladdin and Jasmine jasmine and
Dahlia Dahlia is great there's a lot of
chemistry all around and there's a lot
of energy infused in here it's not
full-blown Guy Ritchie style but there
are a lot of scenes that feel like Guy
Ritchie I feel like they let him have a
scene or two here or there yeah be like
what's a cool visual drink you can throw
on this the way they play with like
frame rate the way they play with like
when scenes are sped up or slowed down
he was a co-writer on this so there's a
certain amount of like comedic dialogue
it's just scenes that are not in the
original Latin movie that really hit as
a matter of fact there's a lot of those
scenes that really shined that weren't
in the original animated movie that is
not something you could say about a lot
of these live-action remake that is
definitely true and I went in most
skeptical of the choice to have Guy
Ritchie do this and it's still one of
those things that's a partial hit for me
on this like part of me would have liked
him maybe even seen like a Bollywood
director get a shot at a movie like this
but I will say that yeah I thought when
the movie was working I could really
feel Guy Ritchie's skill and town
especially fern effects and interesting
camera elements because not all these
movies have the most seamless effects
even on the big huge budget scale and I
thought a lot of the visuals and a lot
of the way they were woven into
everything were pretty impressive
overall oh and I would say in this we
all know like the production the
costumes all that's going to be
wonderful a lot of what I thought would
be bad or cringy
he worked for me in this movie for
starters Will Smith as the genie I know
we already praised him in his but he
really does make it his own and he lets
loose a lot it's not only Will Smith
being Will Smith a different side of
will that we haven't seen in on the big
screen in a long time yeah even the
musical number Prince Holly well it's
not like his vocals have drastically
improved the number itself I wasn't
cringing when I want like the way I
watched it when I saw it on YouTube was
like oh my god this is gonna be horrible
but the lead into that and the overall
tone and vibe and the way they've
established a genie I wasn't watching
that scene cringing I was actually
really enjoying it so far as like still
whatever to me but and I also like what
they invented so I was pretty impressed
I would give it like three and a half
stars out of like a logical technical
point of view an emotional point I had
so much fun that I would give this four
stars yeah I mean I think this is a
movie where everything is is a bit hit
or miss but most of the important
elements I think they really do hit I
like the leads a lot
I like their chemistry a lot you know
there is some really great singing there
is some flat singing there are some
really great visual you know techniques
and elements and stuff like that this is
an example of going back to something
and saying what made that work not just
how exactly do we copy it yeah and I
think Will Smith was the right guy to do
that
not like loving this movie but I had a
really nice time and I was pleasantly
surprised by it so yeah like three at
three and a half I think is a good
rating yeah alright guys well did you
see this Aladdin movie already are you
excited for it do you want to see a
jazmine solo movie you guys can
subscribe to the react nation click that
notification bell make sure to follow us
on the Stardust app if you liked this
video hit the like button and lastly
thank you again RealD 3d for the invite